- All right guys, we only have one night
to finish up this Harry Potter bit,
so just try to focus, get it done.
I'm gonna be out of the office, okay?
- So, you like Harry Potter?
- Yeah. Yeah, I'm totally
into Harry Potter.
- Yeah. Harry Potter's great.
- And wizards, they're so cool.
- What's your favorite part?
- When they're playing quailball.
- Oh yeah, I love that part.
- What's your favorite moment?
- I love when Harry shoots his wand.
Harry Potter shoots the wand.
- Yeah, when he kills Voldesaur?
- Voldesaur, yeah.
- Yes.
- So good.
I was so happy though that Voldesaur
was actually good in the end.
- Yeah, yeah. I mean, George R.R. Martin.
- The catchphrase, he'd always be like,
(British accent) "Not in my house!"
- He took all the gold and
went back to the Dumbledome.
I liked when Harry Potter,
there was that other, the little
(squeaky noise)
- Oh. (squeaky noise)
- Dobbitch?
- Oh, Dobbitch. That's his name.
What is your favorite line
that Harry Potter just says?
- (British accent) "I will do that."
- Remember when his
mom was like, "Harry!"?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- "Harry!"
- "Harry Potter!"
- Yeah. It was like "Harry!".
- Wands don't kill wizards.
- [both] Wizards kill wizards.
- I'm glad that it's a modern movie
with a real happy ending.
- Totally.
- With Hermione and...
- [blonde guy] Harry.
- and Harry Potter getting together.
- Married, yeah.
- When he almost got with Peeta.
- Peeta, yeah.
Peeta's always taking his shirt off
and turning into a wolf, and I'm like,
"You don't wanna end up with that guy".
- Yeah, I get he's like a protector,
he loves you, but like, no.
- Yeah. So you haven't seen Harry Potter?
- No. Did you?
- Oh, absolutely not.
- Okay.
(drum music)